it's not just oil and natural gas
production that's booming we're becoming
a global leader in solar two every four
minutes another American home or
business goes solar every panel pounded
into place by a worker whose job cannot
be outsourced let's continue that
progress with a smarter tax policy that
stops giving four billion dollars a year
to fossil fuel industries that don't
need it so we can invest more and fuels
of the future that do
and even as we've increased energy
production we've partnered with
businesses builders and local
communities to reduce the energy we
consume when we rescued our automakers
for example we worked with them to set
higher fuel efficiency standards for our
cars in the coming months I'll build on
that success by setting new standards
for our trucks so we can keep driving
down oil imports and what we pay at the
pump and taken together our energy
policy is creating jobs and leading to a
cleaner safer planet over the past eight
years the United States has reduced our
total carbon pollution more than any
other nation on earth
but we have to act with more urgency
because a change in climate is already
harming Western communities struggling
with drought and coastal cities dealing
with floods that's why I directed my
administration to work with States
utilities and others to set new
standards on the amount of carbon
pollution our power plants are allowed
to dump into the air the shift the shift
to a cleaner energy economy won't happen
overnight and it will require some tough
choices along the way but the debate is
settled climate change is a fact and
when our children's children look us in
the eye and ask if we did all we could
to leave them a safer more stable world
with new sources of energy I want us to
be able to say yes we did